[Musique]
je suis fini tu là je suis artisan
luthier
alors je suis installé à la réunion
depuis maintenant où il ya une
quarantaine d'années un et j'ai commencé
mon métier en métropole à paris où je
suis né de parents réunionnais j'ai
commencé à travailler dans ce domaine de
la literie depuis l'âge d'à peu près 17
ans
[Musique]
sur une guitare jazz en tamarins je vais
monter des filets en coffre j'ai choisi
le camp parce que c'est un boîtier très
vite et qui a une fibre bien l'ont bien
droite et ça c'est intéressant
alors l'histoire c'est d'arriver à
trouver les filets que j'ai dépité qui
ont la fibre bien parallèles et aux 2
face aux quatre phases du bois pour être
sûr que lorsque je le siv ce bois ne se
cache pas une fois que j'ai choisi mon
bois je vais le cintre et sur un cerf à
ployer
cette affaire qui chauffé comme le bois
et b étaient trempés dos quand il est
trempé d'eau bout d'un moment de irak y
ait des qualités plastiques qui le rend
plus du kiel qui ce qui nous permet avec
la chaleur de de le mettre en forme et
la grande délicatesse de tout ça c'est
de la faire pas trop rapidement pour que
le voile ne s'éclate pas
à luthier c'est un monsieur qui
travaillent dans les instruments à
cordes
c'est une extension à l'origine le
luthier c'était l'artisan qui fabriquait
tous les instruments du quatuor violon
alto violoncelle contrebasse et une main
sur des viols à l'époque où le violon
est apparu pour les musiciens
[Musique]